ボールをある軸の周りに回転させてから別の軸の周りに回転させると、逆の順序で二つの回転を行った場合と同じにはならない
今日のkiss in the classroomでは、このボールが量子コンピュータと最も有名な
量子力学の原理の一つ、不確定性
原理とどう関係しているかを見ていく。kissk in the classroomへようこそ。量子コンピューティング関連のコースで
出会うかもしれない基本的な概念を解説するビデオシリーズだ。各動画には説明欄にリンクされたインタラクティブなモジュールが
付いているので、ぜひチェックしてほしい。今日はハイゼンベルクの不確定性原理について話す。
以前に聞いたことがあるなら、ハイゼンベルクに関する古いジョークも知っているかもしれない。ある日、彼は運転中に警察に止められ、警官に聞かれた：
「今どのくらいのスピードで走っていたか分かるか？」ハイゼンベルクは答えた「いや、でも自分が今どこにいるかは正確に分かる」これはまさに
ハイゼンベルクの不確定性原理の要点だ。粒子の位置と運動量を同時に
完全な精度で知ることはできない。これはよく次のように書かれる。Delta x かける Delta p は
h / 2 以上、ここでDelta XとDelta Pは
位置と運動量の不確かさ、Hは量子力学における極めて小さな基本定数だ
ハイゼンベルクがこの不等式を思いついたのは1927年のことで、電子の位置をどう測定するか想像していた。もし
位置を確認するために光子を電子に当てると、その光子は必ず電子を弾いて運動量を乱してしまう
これは測定がシステムを乱すということだけを言っているのではない。自然から学べることには根本的な
限界があるということを教えてくれる。これは相補性と呼ばれるより広い原理の一例で、
自然のある側面は互いに相容れず、同時に観測できないと
言っている。例えば量子オブジェクトは粒子のように振る舞うこともあれば、波のように振る舞うこともある
が、両方の振る舞いを同時に観測することはできない。ハイゼンベルクの位置と運動量の関係は、
多くの相補的な特徴のセットのうちの一つをカバーしただけだ。この固有の不確かさは、量子力学において
位置や運動量のような性質をどう捉えるかに関係している。XとPを変数や固有の性質として考えるのではなく、
量子力学では位置と運動量はoperatorだ。それらはシステムの性質ではなく、
システムに対して行えることだ。粒子の位置について学ぶには、今そのシステムに対して
操作を行い、測定しなければならない。この操作は、その後に続く他の
操作の結果に影響を与える可能性がある。例えとして乾いた木材のことを考えてみよう。木材には多くの性質がある：
位置、大きさ、形など。また、燃えるという性質と水に浮くという性質もある。もしこの木材が
量子オブジェクトだとしたら、これらは事前に知ることのできる性質ではなくなる。代わりにそれらは
observableと呼ばれる、システムに何らかの操作を行えば学べるものになる。だから燃えやすさや浮きやすさのoperatorを
適用する必要があり、実際に木材を燃やしてみたり水に入れて
浮くかどうか確かめたりしなければならない。各operatorの結果は適用する順序に依存する。もし
最初に燃えやすさをテストすると木材は灰になり、浮くかどうかテストできなくなる。しかし
最初に浮きやすさをテストすると、濡れすぎて燃えなくなる。燃えやすさと
浮きやすさのoperatorはcommuteしないと言う。操作の順序が重要なのだ。これは
この木材について二つのobservableをどの程度知れるかの根本的な限界につながる。なぜなら
測定の文脈を知らずに燃えるかどうか、浮くかどうかを確実に言えないからだ。もちろん実際の木材なら
半分に切って両方の性質を同時にテストできる。でも量子粒子ではそんなことはできない。この
木材の例えはあくまで例えに過ぎない。不確かさは量子力学に固有のものだ。XとPもcommuteしない
そしてこの非可換性こそがハイゼンベルクの不確定性原理につながる。一般に、commuteしない任意の二つのoperatorには
それ自身の不確定性原理がある。不確定性原理の一般形は
次のように書ける。Delta a かける Delta
B は
1/2 かける aとbのブラケット以上、ここで
このブラケットは
commutatorと呼ばれ、最初にaを次にbを適用した場合と、
最初にbを次にaを適用した場合の差に等しい。ここのangle bracketは
内部の期待値を取ることを意味する。基本的に同じ
測定を何度も繰り返した場合、期待値はすべての測定値の平均だ。今日は
IBMの量子コンピュータ上で実際にこの不確定性原理をテストして検証する。一つのqubitの三つの異なる
observableを見て、それらのoperatorがcommuteしないことを示し、最終的に
不確定性原理がこれらのqubitのobservableに対して成り立つことを証明できる。まず、量子
状態を視覚化するのに便利な方法について少し説明する。qubitはBloch球と呼ばれる球面上のどこかを指すベクトルで表せる。
これは以前の動画で扱い、説明欄にリンクがあるが、ここでも簡単に復習する。これが
Bloch球だ。各ベクトルは二つの角度ThetaとFによってパラメータ化されている
状態ゼロは北極にあり、状態1は南極にある。ゼロと1の等しい重ね合わせは
赤道上のどこかにあり、fは重ね合わせの二つの部分の相対位相に等しい
だからここにあるこの状態は
1 / √2 × |0⟩ + e のi乗 × |1⟩に等しい。ここでiはその
位相だ。qubitのobservableを測定するとき、結果は常にqubitの二つの
可能な状態に対応する二択のどちらかになる。これから行う実験では三つのobservableと
対応するoperator X、Y、Zを見ていく。これらのobservableを測定すると+1か
-1のどちらかが得られ、それぞれの確率はBloch球上のqubitのベクトルと
測定軸の間の角度に依存する。予想通り、ZはZ軸に沿って、XはX軸に沿って、
YはY軸に沿って測定する。observableについて話しているのを忘れないでほしい。量子
システムでは、測定なしにシステムについて何かを知ることはもうできないからだ
各observableには対応する操作がある。測定には操作が必要だからだ。分かりにくいかもしれないが、
これらのobservable x、y、zのそれぞれに対応するoperatorと呼ばれる操作は、
各軸の周りでπ回転することだ。XはX軸周りの回転、Y
はY軸周りの回転、ZはZ軸周りの回転だ。これらのoperatorがcommuteするかどうかを確認するには、球面上での回転が
commuteするかどうかを確認すればいい。もしcommuteするなら、不確定性原理は適用されず、qubitのX、Y、Zを
完全な精度で知ることができる。commuteしないなら、qubitの新しい不確定性関係を見つけられる。
このボールの点を見ていてほしい。最初にX軸周りに回転させて次にY軸周りに回転させると、ここに
行き着く。では逆の順序で試してみよう。最初にY軸周りに回転させて、
次にX軸周りに回転させると、ここに行き着く。だから確かにcommuteしない。つまり
qubitのX、Y、Zの値を同時に正確に知ることはできず、
不確定性関係が存在する。詳細は省くが、最終的に三つの異なる不確定性
関係が得られる。Delta x かける Delta Y は
|⟨Z⟩|以上、Delta y かける Delta Z は
|⟨X⟩|以上、Delta Z かける Delta X は
|⟨Y⟩|以上だ。つまりこれらの不確かさのどの二つの積も、常に
第三のobservableの期待値以上になる。Qiskitを使って
状態ゼロのZとXを両方測定しようとすると何が起きるか見てみよう。Zの測定は簡単で、これはいわゆる標準基底だ
量子コンピュータの測定はデフォルトで常にZ方向だ。しかしXを測定するには基底変換と呼ばれるものを行う必要がある。
基本的にはBloch球を回転させてXが以前Zがあった場所を上に向けるようにする。これを行うには
Hadamard gateを使う。完全なQuantum circuitはこうなる：Z方向に測定し、Hadamardを適用し、
そしてX方向に測定する。QiskitのPrimitive samplerを使ってこの実験を何度も実行すると
測定結果のヒストグラムが得られる。Z方向の
測定はこうなり、X方向の測定はこうなる。見ての通り、
qubitはZ方向に沿ってほぼ100%の確実性でゼロ状態にあると測定されたが、
X方向ではqubit状態についてほとんど何も分からなかった。ゼロか1かが等しい
確率で測定され、Xでの不確かさは最大に近かった。これで
不確かさのトレードオフについて少し感覚がつかめた。しかし量子コンピュータ上でもう少しうまくできる。
Qiskitのprimitive estimatorを使ってobservable X、Y、ZとそれぞれのRの期待値を求めることができる。
不確かさも求められる。Bloch球上でX+方向を向く状態で試してみよう。estimatorを使って
この状態のxとzの不確かさと期待値を計算する。
yについても計算する。この状態でQiskitからこの結果が得られる。xとyの二つの
不確かさの積を取ると、予想通りyの期待値の絶対値より
大きくなっている。しかしこれは特定の一つの状態についてだけだ。この不等式が
すべてのqubit状態で成り立つことを確かめたい。だからestimatorをもう一度使うが、今度はパラメータ値をスキャンして
与えたすべてのパラメータ値で期待値を求める。スキャンしたいパラメータは
Bloch球上の角度Thetaで、XZ平面に交差するこのArc上にある
すべてのqubit状態について不等式を確認する。これを行うと角度Thetaの関数としてプロットが得られる。赤い
曲線は二つの不確かさの積、オレンジの曲線はyの期待値だ。予想通り、
xとzの不確かさの積はyの期待値よりはるかに大きい。しかしこれは
不等式を満たすのはそれほど難しくなかった。このArc上のすべての状態でyの期待値がゼロと非常に小さかったからだ
Theta値を同様にスキャンしてみよう。ただし今度はXZ平面でスキャンするのではなく、5をpi/
4に設定する。球面上の別のArc上にあるqubit状態を見ていく。ここでは不等式が
もう少し厳しくテストされる。オレンジの曲線と赤い曲線が近くなっているが、赤は常にオレンジより上にある
そして不確定性原理はまだ成り立っている。まだすべての状態を確認したわけではないが、うまくいけば感覚が
つかめてきたはずだ。量子システムの相補的な任意の二側面には根本的な不可知性がある
このqubitもそうだ。不確定性原理は、どれだけ頑張っても、どれだけ巧みな測定をしても、
完全な精度ですべてを知ることは絶対にできないという事実に向き合わせてくれる
本当に逃げ道はない。信じてくれなくても、信じてくれても、挑戦してほしい。説明欄にリンクされたモジュールを見て、
不確定性原理を打ち破ってみてほしい。視聴してくれてありがとう、また次回